l'univers d'harry potter débarqua
plaisir une boutique de 150 mètres
carrés a ouvert début décembre dans la
galerie commerciale d'auchan
c'est le deuxième établissement de ce
type dans les yvelines après celui de
chambourcy l'idée viande halal a fait
d'eux des fondateurs et en partant à
londres à des à son papa je ne comprends
pas il n'y a pas de boutique et harry
potter en france donc de là est venu à
l'idée
donc maintenant il ya 13 boutiques en
france ici les produits les plus vendus
sur les baguettes des films les clients
peuvent également retrouver des dizaines
de produits à l'effigié du célèbre
sorcier dont des éditions limitées et
pour tout le monde tout ce que harry
potter c'est intergénérationnel
par contre c'est vraiment plus pour les
fans je pense car vraiment ils peuvent
venir nous voir on peut discuter avec
eux et on s'y connaît très bien dans le
domaine et eux aussi également ça fait
toujours plaisir de connaître avec
quelqu'un et la magie a l'air d'opérer
chaque jour plusieurs centaines de fans
ou de curieux scrute avec attention les
nouveautés dans la boutique
c'est très bien il ya vraiment beaucoup
de chance on retrouve les boutiques que
j'ai fait à travers le monde on va dire
voilà yavo c'est sympa d'en avoir
plusieurs en région parisienne on est
super content plutôt que devoir aller à
londres
oula oula y avait des vraies grosses
boutiques harry potter ici on est sur
une boutique de petite envergure mais
avec un choix exceptionnel le business
d'harry potter n'est pas prêt de
s'essouffler dans les yvelines une
nouvelle boutique le repère des sorciers
devrait voir le jour d'ici mars 2021
dans la commune de montesson